Dr Zakia relating to the application of
alul or black eyeliner as we know it is
Sunnah it is a sunah of the Prophet
Muhammad sallallah alaihi wasallam may
Allah bless him um is it something which
is permitted during the fast as far as
putting alcohol in our country India
it's called a surma or uh Black Island
it's Sunnah of the prophet and we get in
thei that pleased with him you should
always stay with the prophet he used to
cook his food also and he used to put
this alcohol and Prophet never
prohibited him even when he put during
fasting so this proves that putting
cohol does not break the fast it is
permitted and even when you put any ey
drops or ear
drops even if the year drops or drops
after a certain time you can feel the
taste in the throat according to most of
the scholars it does not invalidate the
fast because that is not the normal
passage of food and ey drops these are
medicines they aren't food and there are
times that because you know that I'm
being a medical doctor the ears nose and
throat they're connected known as
ent ent ear nose throat so when you put
eye drops even the ear drops you know
nasle drops there are chances after some
time it may go into the throat and you
may feel the taste if in the nle drop we
should throw it out but ear drops and
eye drops You Feel The Taste according
to most of the scholars it does not
break the fast but there are some
Scholars who say that if it reaches the
throat it will nfy the fast but the
right ruling is that because it's not
the normal passage for food and drink
according to most of the scholars it
does not nfy the fast and if someone
who's has a doubt the best for him is he
delays putting those nasal drops after
Sunset so he absolutely safe but the
right ruling is that even you put a
nasal drop or your drop it does not
break the fast